hey what's up my name's samuel leeson
right now on this video i got some great
news for you i am going to be
paying
the utility bills because utility bills
right now are going crazy gas electric
all that stuff so we're going to be
paying the utility bills of one of our
subscribers completely off for the
entire rest of 2022.
that means that you watching this video
might not have to think about any of
your bills for the rest of the year and
let me in this video explain how to
apply for this and also why i'm doing it
i'm doing it because right now utility
bills energy prices are going up so
ridiculously high i know it's literally
going to mean that some people are going
to struggle to even afford to just live
a basic think about this the average
salary is two thousand pounds a month
the average rent now is one thousand
pounds a month that means half your
salary is gone
utility bills are generally speaking a
few hundred pounds a month they're
doubling right now that means that
people are going to have like two three
hundred pounds left on average a month
and they haven't even eaten a meal you
know what this is this is ridiculous and
not only am i training people and trying
to teach people how to become
financially independent but i'm also
wanting to just write someone's bills
off for the entire rest of the year so
in a moment i'm going to talk about how
to apply for that it's very very very
easy
make sure you apply but what i want to
talk about right now before i talk about
how to apply is how is all these energy
prices going up how is this going to
affect property investors especially
people doing rent to rents let me
explain what rental rent is rent to rent
is when you rent a house
and then you turn the house into a hmo
or a service department and then you
re-rent it out on a correct management
agreement so it's completely legal for a
much higher amount
for example you might rent a house or
rent an apartment for 700 pounds a month
in brighton
and then you put the property on airbnb
and you're bringing in 3 000 pounds a
month and all that extra income is your
monthly profit this is an incredible
strategy to replace your income through
a job and just to become financially
independent people are saying but if
energy prices are going up when you're
doing rent to rent you need to pay for
the bills
so if you're doing rent to hmo or rent
to service accommodation how's this
going to affect and the answer is it's
very very very simple it's not going to
affect rent to rent hardly at all
because if part of the service when
you're renting out let's say you've got
a hmo and you're charging 500 pounds a
month per room well that includes the
energy bills if energy bills go up then
you're just going to put the rents up
it's obvious and the person paying for
500 pounds a month is going to know that
energy prices have gone up so it's just
going to mean that your profit as the
rent to enter is exactly the same so
it's not really going to affect it i
tell you what it will affect it will
affect people that are in jobs if you're
in a job you're an employee and you're
having to pay for your gas electric
council tax all your bills and then
you're also having to pay for your rent
or your mortgage
you're going to be left right now with
very very little martin lewis recently
came out and said
that he is out of ideas martin lewis
from money's supermarket expert said
i can't help you anymore this is
absolutely crazy so i believe that the
best way i can help you is not only by
paying off your utility bills for the
rest of the year of course that's great
but i can't do that for everyone okay if
i did that for everybody i would go
bankrupt myself because there's millions
of people in the uk so what i'm doing is
i am going to be touring across the
country i'm going to brighton this month
okay later this month in may 2022 i'm
going to brighton i'm going to
manchester london birmingham i'm going
to cross the country and i'm going to be
running a one-day program it's going to
be completely free and i'm going to be
teaching people how in 2022 they can
take grip of their finances and how they
can use the rent to rent strategy and
become financially independent quickly
through property right now starting with
nothing so if that sounds good to you
get booked on below now let me tell you
how to enter the the prize draw if you
want to have your bills paid off for the
rest of the year i'm going to be
choosing one person who is registered on
the rent to rent training day so if you
want to get your bills paid off for a
year what's going to happen is in the
description below there's the rent to
rent revolution it's free okay there's a
one pound booking fee
book below i'm going to be taking once
the rent to rent tour is finished i'm
going to be taking one person that
registered on the link below and i'm
going to be contacting them and telling
them that i'm paying off their bills for
the rest of the year so if you want that
to be you you're gonna number one
click the link below get registered then
you're gonna have a load of free
training you're gonna meet me in person
and then i'm gonna be choosing one
person at random and paying off their
bills for the rest of the year if that
sounds like a fair deal to you if that
sounds like a win-win get booked get
registered i can't wait to train you i
can't wait to work with you and
hopefully paying off your bills for the
rest of 2022 get registered i'll see you
soon
[Music]